the lines of ambulances at accident and
emergency departments has been for
months a telling sign of how stretched
hospitals have become at Salford Royal
the Handover of patients appeared to be
going pretty smoothly despite the steady
flow of weekend arrivals
having too many ambulances will be the
least of anyone's worries come Wednesday
in advance of the start of strike action
by ambulance Crews the letter from
Health Chiefs says hospitals should take
action to cope with what they say will
be extensive disruption and a very
challenging period
the letter requests what it calls
essential actions including ensuring
measures are in place to ensure
ambulances can hand over patients no
later than 15 minutes after their
arrival and efforts to free up maximum
bed capacity by safely discharging
patients in advance of the industrial
action it perhaps begs the question why
they wouldn't be doing that anyway the
chances of it happening appear Slim
the head of NHS providers said that with
the operational pressures they're facing
right now High bed occupancy Rising
emissions with flu covered pressures
record staff absences and increasing
numbers arriving at a e departments like
this it will be incredibly difficult for
them to do what they're being asked
and even if they could free up beds some
say that risks creating other problems
the issue is that social care has been
on the back burner for far too long
under successive governments and really
now we've got to a crisis point where
we've got our own recruitment issue and
there aren't as many staff in the
community to help um when people are
discharged we want to help the Health
Service we want to help those hard-press
analyst workers and the nurses but um
we've got our own issues and I hope the
government will take steps to resolve
this as quickly as possible
a winter of disruption in the health
service has already seen the largest
strike in NHS history after nurses on
the picket line around 10 000 ambulance
workers are going on strike across 10
ambulance trusts in England and Wales in
the Northwest the GMB Union has said it
will provide the equivalent of just one
crew per station to respond to
life-threatening and emergency calls
between unions showing no sign of
backing down and a government not
willing to negotiate the rest of us in
the depths of winter are left hoping we
don't pay the price Greg Milam Sky News
Salford